PETE LEPAGE: Hey everybody, and
welcome to another edition
of Chrome Apps Office Hours.
We've got a special Chrome Apps
Office Hours-- that's a
mouthful to say, always--
today, where we've brought in
two special guests, the
developers behind
the Reditr app.
So guys, let me bring you
up and say welcome.
Thanks for joining us.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Thanks for
introducing us, there.
And, yeah, as you said,
we developed
an app called Reditr.
It's a really cool app, we
think, and it lets you
basically browse Reddit on
your desktop in a neat
column-based design, as
you can see here.
So Dimitry, do you want
to explain maybe a
bit about the app?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well,
basically what's nice about
the columns is that it serves
as a feed of all the data--
like any custom feed that
you want from Reddit.
So you could have like a custom
search feed, multiple
subreddit feed, and if you have
it sorted by new, it'll
pull in new posts over
an interval.
And it'll be a live experience
of Reddit.
PETE LEPAGE: Very cool.
And so this is something that
you guys have been working on
for quite a while,
haven't you?
Or how long have you guys
been working on this?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV:
Since October--
well, we released October
of last year, so yeah.
We've been working a little
bit over a year now.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So this is something that
you guys have built.
Did it start off as a
Chrome packaged app?
Or where did you
start with it?
Where were you doing it
in the very beginning?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: It's kind of a
funny story, actually, because
Dimitry and I came home from
school one day, and Dimitry
said, I'm bored.
I want to make a really
cool Reddit client.
Then I said, oh, cool,
good luck with that.
And then Dimitry started
looking into
developing in Qt--
C++ using the Qt framework.
And I frowned at Dimitry and
said, well, why do it in Qt
when you have this beautiful
HTML5 to design this rich
experience in?
So probably for the next month
after we decided we'd do it in
HTML5, we were looking for like
a way to publish our app.
I said, you know, we don't want
to make a boring website.
We want to make a full
desktop app.
So we were looking at maybe
XULRunner with Firefox, and
Appcelerator had a really
cool way to publish
desktop apps in HTML5.
But we stumbled upon the Chrome
App Store, and we
really fell in love with that
just because of the rich API
they give us, and it's just so
easy to make an app using the
Chrome API.
PETE LEPAGE: So that was about a
year or so ago, and that was
with the sort of v1 Chrome
packaged apps
that you did this.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: So what did you
like about the Chrome Packaged
App platform at the time that
sort of said, OK, yeah this is
definitely where we want
to go with this?
What were some of
the key things?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well, first
of all, it just felt
really easy to distribute
through the Chrome Web Store,
plus it was kind of new.
It was nice to be like one of
the early, I guess-- maybe a
year isn't too early,
but still.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: We're just two
guys, and we don't have any
marketing experience at all.
We're first-year university
students, so we had no way of
going up to all these people
and saying, here
guys, here's our app.
We hope you enjoy it.
So the Chrome Store, that really
eliminated that problem
for us, because we just
put the app right
on the Chrome store.
And then instantly whoever
searches Reddit on the store,
they'll see Reditr, and they'll
get it that way.
So it sort of levels the playing
field in that sense,
because big companies who
publish apps onto the store,
they have the chance of people
finding their apps as just two
kids have of people finding
our own app.
So that's what we were
really excited about
with the Chrome Store.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So as we're going
through today--
I just put a link up on screen,
but for those of you
who are watching at home live,
if you have questions, feel
free to post your questions to
our Google Moderator queue.
The URL is just there
at goo.gl/knzHf.
And that H is a capital.
And so a shout out to you guys,
because you guys are in
school right now.
And you're in school out in
the Maritimes, right?
In Canada?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Yep.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Very nice.
What school are you guys at?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: I'm going
to Dalhousie.
I'm getting a computer
science degree.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: I'm going
to Saint Mary's University.
I'm taking a mathematics
and finance degree.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
Very nice.
So interesting--
mathematics and finance, and
you're doing computer science?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Yeah.
At first it started off as a
hobby, but then it kind of
grew on me.
PETE LEPAGE: That works.
Awesome.
So as you guys started working
on the v1, and, I guess,
working on your app today, what
kind of libraries and
frameworks were you using
to get the great
app that you have?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So in terms of
the third-party libraries
we're using that we absolutely
depend on every day, the
answer's going to be jQuery,
just like pretty
much everyone else.
And it just makes everything
so simple.
And we wrote our own library
for interfacing with the
Reddit API, just because not a
really good JavaScript one had
existed before.
So we're heavily dependent on
jQuery and then our own little
library for that.
Other than those two libraries,
I don't really
think we utilized many more,
with the exception of, of
course, the Chrome APIs that are
offered to us within the
Chrome extension.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So did you guys do the design
work for the experience all
from scratch on your own?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: In earlier
versions of the app,
everything was our own, but over
time we had people giving
suggestions and everything like
that, so we've used a lot
of help from the Reddit
community and everyone who's
been using the app.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow.
That's pretty fantastic.
It's really a beautiful app, and
it's got a really app-like
experience, which
is nice to see.
A lot of people who build Chrome
packaged apps still
think about apps as sort of
websites, and the experience
is kind of still websitey.
But the point of a Chrome
packaged app is that it's not.
It's an installed application
that you use on your desktop
computer or your laptop or
wherever that just works and
feels appy.
And trying to define that appy
experience is sometimes a
little bit tough.
When you guys were working
through that app-like
experience, what were some of
the things that you were
thinking about for creating an
experience and a UI that
looked and felt like an app?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So one thing
that we hope users notice
right off the bat is that this
is something called a
frameless app.
And it doesn't have the
traditional bar along the top
with the close buttons
and whatnot.
We actually built our own close,
minimize, and maximize
buttons in JavaScript, and we
built it such that we wanted
to mimic the operating system
that the app's installed on.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, interesting.
So do you change for the
different operating systems?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Yeah.
That's correct.
We do.
So if you'll notice here, you
see the Mac UI up in the top
left, and that's just
like the standard
Mountain Lion window controls.
But if you were to install this
on Windows or Linux, then
you'd see a completely different
experience in terms
of the window controls.
And that's something we do in
JavaScript, and we couldn't
actually do that without
Chrome and the Chrome
Extension v2 packaged app, so.
PETE LEPAGE: Oh, really?
Cool.
Very nice.
You guys have been--
I guess for about maybe three
weeks or so now-- working on
bringing this app to
a v2 packaged app.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: What has been
your experience on
doing that so far?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well, so
far, after we solved the
cross-domain issues,
it's actually been
going pretty smoothly.
The main issue was just
cross-domain.
As soon as we got past
cross-domain, everything was
just smooth as butter,
transferring it over.
PETE LEPAGE: So let's talk
about that a little bit.
So one of the things we first
started, when we had our first
conversation that we talked a
little bit about is you guys
had looked at this, and
you had hit like
four sort of big problems.
And content security policy and
cross-domain was sort of
the first one to mind.
What was the problem there and
how did you end up solving it?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well, the
problem was with Chrome v2
packaged apps, it didn't let
you, for example, set an SRC
tag on an image that went
to an external--
to a different website, and with
Reddit, where links are
shared everywhere.
And if you want to embed an
image into the app, you can't
just link it to the
other website.
So what we did is any time an
image tag comes up on the app,
we just add a little attribute
to it, and then with an
interval, we search through the
DOM for every image tag
that has that attribute, and
then we download it--
DAVID ZORYCHTA: In
the background.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: In the
background, yeah, and then we
get the blob and then
stick it as an SRC
tag, and then it works.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, so you're
effectively sort of grabbing
those images.
Now, are you saving them to
disk, or are you just keeping
them in memory, or what are you
doing with them once you
get them from the server?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: I believe
they're just stored in memory.
I don't believe that
they get cached.
I'm not 100% certain on that.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: At the moment,
I can tell you here--
it's funny, because it sounds
like it's this big complicated
procedure, but, in fact, it's
about 10, 11 lines of code.
So it's actually not--
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Yeah.
It wasn't like hours of work.
It was just checking if we're
in a Chrome v2 packaged app,
and then just changing a
couple lines of code.
It wasn't that difficult.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So content security policy is
sort of one of those ones a
lot of developers run into on
their first try when they
convert an app.
And it's really about because
these apps have access to APIs
and hardware that the drive-by
web really doesn't normally
have access to, it's really
important to make sure that
users are well-protected here.
And that's why we implement
these rules, so that you can't
go and grab source from
someplace else and start
injecting it.
You can't accidentally have
somebody do a cross-site
scripting attack, where they're
grabbing their source
and inserting it
into your app.
But it does mean that there's
a little bit more fun.
Now, one of the things that I
shared with you guys early on
was the Chrome Asset Loader.
Did you end up using that or did
you end up doing your own
thing after seeing that
and going, oh, OK.
We see what's going on.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: We saw what
it was doing, and we just
implemented just a slightly
simpler version.
And then that's about it.
We just [? call ?] one function
every time you see an
image, and that's about it.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Interesting.
So what were some of the other
challenges that you guys faced
as you were working through
porting the app over?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So the other
biggest challenge that we
faced was the accessibility
of cookies.
So you can't, through
JavaScript, access
document.cookie.
It just doesn't let you.
And that's kind of unfortunate,
because Reddit--
the API--
it's dependent on cookies.
So we had to build a little
bit of a work-around--
like around logging into Reddit
and authenticating with
Reddit, because we didn't have
access to setting cookies, for
example, or even reading
cookies.
But that didn't take that long
to fix that issue, either--
probably only about an hour.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: First we
went to OAuth, thinking that
we couldn't fix it, but then--
DAVID ZORYCHTA: But we sent you
guys an email, actually,
and you came back to us and
had a brilliant solution.
We implemented that.
So it was pretty straightforward
after we got
your email.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So what was that--
so you were using the OAuth
implementation.
And when you were using that
one, were you using the
Identity API?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: No.
Actually we had written an OAuth
implementation earlier
on for another project, so
since we just needed to
implement this for testing
reasons, we used that.
But I think actually in V2
packaged apps, there's an
API-to-Interface OAuth
directly, right?
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
There is.
And it's a relatively new API.
It's still an experimental API,
so if you use it today,
you can't upload your app to
the Chrome Web Store yet.
That should come out of
experimental within the next
release or two.
My guess is in the next release,
not the one that's
coming up in a couple
of weeks, but the
release after that.
And that will allow you to
authenticate against any
authentication provider,
whether they're
using OAuth or whatever.
They could be using their
own sort of magic there.
And then there's a second API
that lets you authenticate
against the Google APIs.
So for developers who want to
go and authenticate up to a
Google service.
Say, for example, you want to
store stuff on the user's
Google Drive, or you want to
go and just figure out who
this user is, you can use
that particular API.
So what was the solution you
guys ended up using, then?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So what we
figured out was even though we
couldn't like pragmatically
access cookies, they're
actually being set anyway.
So we actually figured out that
we can make a request to
Reddit and then let them
handle all the
cookie mess for us.
We didn't have to set any
cookies ourselves.
And then it just sort of
erased the problem.
We were really lucky that they
actually did that for us.
PETE LEPAGE: Nice.
Now when you talk to Reddit,
how are you doing that?
Because to do that cross-domain
request gets a
little bit interesting.
Are you doing it with a sandbox
iframe, are you doing
it with a WebView?
What's your communication
process look like between your
app and the Reddit API?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So every get
request is actually just a
normal AJAX request, and
I believe every post
request is, as well.
They are cross-domain requests,
and we just
implement the necessary
restriction removal within the
security policy.
So, for example, every time we
need to access a website URL
on reddit.com, within the
content security policy that
our app uses, it has reddit.com
within that.
So it knows that we as
the developers--
we know it's safe to access
reddit.com, therefore it's
safe for the users to
access reddit.com.
So it started with the CSP.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Now let's talk about some of the
enhancements you guys were
able to add because of some of
the new features with Chrome
packaged apps with
the v2 stuff.
Was there anything that you were
able to take advantage of
there to enhance
the experience?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Definitely
there was.
For one, as I mentioned before,
the frameless app.
So you don't have this bar along
the top of your screen
for the app.
It's just built right into the
window itself, so this just
feels so native because you have
the window controls built
right into the actual WebView.
So that's definitely one of
the coolest things that we
were able to do.
And then the second thing is
the fact that you could
actually use Chrome Storage
to store user data.
Now, we haven't implemented the
syncing yet through Chrome.
Right now we actually run
off a shared web host.
And as we get more and more
users, it takes longer and
longer to sync.
But thanks to Google, we'll
just be able to sync
everything through Google and
just eliminate the necessity
of having to juggle syncing
by ourselves.
So that's going to be the
coolest thing we do.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, do you guys
have a syncing service running
somewhere that you guys
maintain today?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Yes.
We actually use justhost for
that-- it's just a shared web
host, because we can't afford
anything really that big.
PETE LEPAGE: So that's
that a huge advantage
I guess, for users.
And being able to store stuff
just between machines and
sessions so that if I'm signed
in on one computer--
hey, here's all my stuff.
I go to another computer.
All of that stuff is
synced across.
Now, do you plan to use
both the local storage
and the sync storage?
Or are you just going
to end up using
sync storage primarily?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: We'll probably
make it so that like only the
essential elements are
synced so that
we're not like clogging--
putting a lot of clutter
into the cloud.
We'll probably take advantage of
both local and sync storage
combinations.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
One thing to keep in mind is
that there is a limit to the
amount of stuff that you can
put into the sync storage.
So I think it's something
around 512 items or 1024
items, and each one can be a
maximum of 4K or something to
that extent.
So you can't put the entire
world into it, but you can put
a fair amount of stuff.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Yeah--
a reasonable amount for a
Reddit client like ours.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
Exactly.
Cool.
And then as well with the
frameless stuff, what did you
have to change to get it to be
frameless so that it didn't
have the native bar
across the top?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So at first when
we set out to do this, we
had no clue what
we were doing.
But actually we just a quick
Google search on Chrome 2 v2
frameless app, and Google
actually has like 100
different projects
and all their
source visible on GitHub.
So one of them happened
to be a frameless app.
PETE LEPAGE: Perfect.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: So we
just went ahead.
We downloaded that.
And to actually drag
around the app--
that's kind of fishy
right now.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: I
don't think you can
see it on the screen.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Oh, right.
Well, you can just click and
drag the app, and, of course,
that's something you need to
implement as a developer
yourself, because you don't have
the Chrome around the app
to do that.
So it's one line of CSS.
And just looking at the source
that Google provided, we found
that out in about
five minutes.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
pretty great.
So what were some of
the resources?
You mentioned the GitHub
repository.
But what are some of the other
resources that you found
helpful in building
your Chrome app?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Stack
Overflow, for sure--
a lot of hours spent there
just in general.
Other than that, the Google
documentation's actually
pretty good for v2 Packaged.
And, as I said, like the 100
different projects that you
guys offer--
all the source code.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: That
was a lot of help.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: A lot of help.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So what are some of the things
that you guys are thinking
about adding to this as a Chrome
Packaged App or just in
general feature-wise
in the future?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well,
we want to see if we can
implement like an offline kind
of feature, where it'll cache
like maybe the first maybe
two, three pages of each
column, and if you remember
something that you wanted to
show your friends or something,
you don't have to
connect to the internet and
redownload everything.
PETE LEPAGE: That's cool.
What APIs are you thinking about
will be useful for that?
How are you thinking about
implementing that?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: We haven't
really looked enough into it
to know exactly what we
want to use, but we'll
have to take a look.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Just off the top of my head,
there's a couple I think that
will be interesting.
The Chrome Storage Local
would be one.
But there's another one that--
I guess there's two that
are interesting.
There's the Sync FileSystem
which works very much like the
HTML5 file system, that allows
you to store resources on the
user's computer.
So you can store data, you can
store images, files, whatever.
So you can use that.
And because it's the synced file
system, it actually syncs
to the user's Google Drive
account, so they could store
stuff up there.
They've got access to it on any
computer they go to, and
you're pretty much golden
across all the different
devices you might
be signed in on.
Then the other one is the--
and I'm completely
blanking on it.
There was Sync FileSystem
and the--
all right, I'll have to come
back to it, because I'm
blanking on it.
Love those kinds of days.
Cool.
So what are your next steps
to get this into
the Chrome Web Store?
What else do you guys have to
do in order to publish it?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well, there
are some minor bugs with
pulling images.
Like, for example, albums--
they don't seem to
work as well.
The images just aren't being
pulled properly.
But that shouldn't too big
of a problem to fix.
It's just looking at
the code again.
What else?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Really just
minor bugs that when we seed
it out to some testers, they'll
be able to give us
some good feedback on.
And we can get back to them
and sort of solve their
problems, hopefully.
And then we should be actually
ready to release then.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
That's fantastic.
And from the time you guys
started working on the v2 app
to getting something working,
how long do you think that
took, all total?
Just to get it working, not
necessarily to have it perfect.
But like, all right,
this is working.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV:
Within a week.
It wasn't that difficult.
It was just changing
some manifests--
some spots in the manifest, but
really that's about it.
And some cross--
it was purely CSP.
PETE LEPAGE: OK. so CSP was
really the big thing.
And then to get it to that like
place where you're going
to be happy with it, how long
do you think it would take
you, has taken you, to
get to that stage?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Just in raw
hours of just pure coding,
probably only like eight hours,
considering that we
also added additional features
there as well to make the
experience better
for the users.
So not long at all.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
That's actually pretty
fantastic.
And it helps, I think, for
developers who are watching
this and considering building or
porting their app from a v1
packaged app or a web app,
seeing real developers say
that this is what it takes.
And this is a great app.
This offers a full set of
features, has a really nice
experience--
it really says a lot about this
experience and moving
this forward.
Have you guys thought about
monetization strategies?
Do you plan to make some money
with this, or are you going to
use this to pay for school,
or what are
your thoughts on that?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: It's
definitely on our minds, but
we're not 100% sure how we're
going to do it with the
desktop, but we're also planning
on moving on to
mobile platforms.
And we're actually
in the process of
doing that right now.
So hopefully either through--
I think it was like
a freemium model.
I forget what the model was
called, but there's a free
version with ads, and another
one that's paid that
doesn't have ads.
But we're not 100% certain
with the desktop version.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
Well, certainly freemium is
an interesting model.
We're getting ready to release
in-app payments to allow users
to pay within the app a certain
amount of money.
So maybe that means unlocking
a certain set of features.
But actually you mentioned
mobile.
Let's talk about
that for a sec.
How are you approaching
the mobile app?
What are you doing to build
a mobile experience?
DAVID ZORYCHTA: It's funny you
mention that, actually,
because right now we have
a fully functional
HTML5 mobile version.
And it's actually built
for Firefox OS.
It runs pretty well on
Firefox OS, actually.
It was really fun to make.
In terms of Android development,
we're doing that
in Java, and for the iPhone,
we're doing that in
Objective-C.
The reason being mostly,
actually, we just want to sort
of like learn--
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Yeah,
get another skill set.
It will be nice to have.
PETE LEPAGE: Interesting.
OK.
For the Android and for the iOS
versions that you're doing
native, are you using WebViews
at all to render any of the
content, or are you doing
everything purely native?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well
for article previews--
so if someone linked to a New
York Times article, we would
use a WebView for that.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
But everything else is a--
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Everything
else, yeah.
PETE LEPAGE: Wow.
That's a great learning
experience.
I'll be interested to hear how
you guys, as you get further
along in this project, see how
they compare, and then
maintaining multiple code bases
across different platforms.
One of the things we hear a lot
from developers is that it
is a pain to maintain all
of those code bases.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Just
especially with only two
people, it's already getting
pretty hectic.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
One of the things that we've
talked about with Chrome apps
is the ability to be able to
take your existing Chrome app
and wrap it with Cordova,
which is also known as
PhoneGap, and be able to have
a fully fledged version that
works for mobile, whether phone,
tablet, Android, iOS,
without having to change
very much code.
Realistically, you'll need to
change a few things, because a
screen this big doesn't
necessarily work so well on a
screen this big.
But that's potentially just some
CSS changes, depending on
how things are laid out.
So that's certainly something
to look at if you guys ever
hit the point where you're
like, uh, we want to keep
maintaining this, but not do
three different versions.
Cool.
Well, guys, we're
almost at time.
Is there anything you guys want
to add or anything you
want to share with
the folks who are
watching live right now?
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Well, if
you want to follow our
progress on any of our
developments, either mobile or
the Chrome version, you can
visit our subreddit, which is
just reddit.com/r/reditr.
Our Twitter is just Reditr,
and our website's just
reditr.com.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Let me pop that up
on screen so that
folks can see it there.
So if you want to try or grab
Reditr, you can grab it from
that URL that's there
on screen.
And it'll be up hopefully very
shortly in the Chrome Web
Store-- the new version.
The current one works
beautifully, but it is a
Chrome packaged app v1, so
hopefully we'll see v2 in
there in the near future.
Well guys, thanks very
much for joining me.
Hopefully this was useful for
folks who are watching, and
you guys all learned
a little bit.
And thanks very much.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: Thank you.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: Thanks
for having us.
PETE LEPAGE: See you guys.
DIMITRY VINOGRADOV: See ya.
DAVID ZORYCHTA: See ya.